[Music]
welcome to the amber ruffin show the
only late night show that's proven to
fight cavities
we're filming in studio 8g at
rockefeller center where seth meyers
films his show
late night with seth meyers now we don't
have a studio audience but we do have
a terry davis he's my announcer sidekick
and real life friend
say hi terrik hi sarah in addition to
being my sidekick tarek is also an
undercover spy
no i'm not he's got to say that because
he's undercover
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
a michigan woman recently glued her eyes
shut
after she accidentally took fingernail
glue out of her purse
instead of eye drops but on the plus
side she didn't have to see this
the academy award for actor goes to
anthony hopkins that's right
the academy awards were on sunday and
actress
glenn close lost her eighth oscar
nomination but
she did win a source award a b-e-t
award and an naacp image award
okay the woman did the butt
she did the butt like the butt's never
been done before she really did it
it was good doing the button
why don't you spit out that food before
i'm nothing
[Applause]
sorry you guys this show could just be
me and tarek singing songs it mostly is
we just threw jokes in the middle of it
yeah
in an effort to hire more tsa officers
the agency has reportedly been looking
for job candidates on social media
basically they just find people
harassing brown men on twitter and go
hey
don't you do that for free
according to a recent article ufo
sightings in new york have nearly
doubled this year weird weird right
yeah it's freaking weird wait a minute
where's the regular cue card guy he quit
said this show was too weird for him
weird
yeah very weird
the tampa bay buccaneers player rob
gronkowski
recently set a new record after he
caught a football that was dropped 600
feet from a helicopter
the record was for dumbest job and
i say that as someone with this job did
you hear us singing doing the butt
dumb as hell up
left that steak in there for him to eat
yeah
does he think butt means food i think so
so hungry
900 canadians lost their internet
service last weekend
after beavers chewed through an
underground cable that story again
canada state canada
according to reports the ceo of retailer
target
made over 19 million dollars last year
he initially went into target for some
toilet paper and cheez-its and left with
the whole company
okay what happens when you go to target
you guys it's crazy in there never know
what you'll come out with
and finally clean comedy day was this
week
and that was the monologue jack
what's the best part of being a spy i'm
not a spy
you're good in other news it was
announced this week that
new york will lose a congressional seat
in 2023
after the state's census count was short
by
89 people 89 people
they couldn't find an extra 89 people
hell
i think we could count another 89 people
in this room alone
i mean one two
three four five
six 7 8
9 10 11
12 13
71 wait a minute isn't that just
jeff oh sorry sir
for a second you look like my friend
jeff oh
crap i lost count
one two remember um we don't have time
for this
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you